moi tout va bien et notre invité ce
matin c'est Vladimir fais dorots qui
bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous mais partager
et mon accent exactement
on va le voir roman d'une révolution aux
éditions
absolu que j'ai sorti quand vous m'avez
reçu qui s'appelait Poutine l'Ukraine
les faces cachées les clés historiques
géopolitique avec ça les erreurs de
casting dans le dans l'histoire et même
cela prime pour vous j'ai publié vous
savez la structure du livre se fera
qu'on soit disant les choses romanesques
les deux couples le tsar Lénine en
ramenant chaque fois en sourdine à la
crise actuelle mais là dedans il y a un
piment j'ai publié pour la première fois
l'être médite une très grande dame
française qui était la femme de la vie
de Lénine c'est une dame extraordinaire
très pointue et Ina charmante et ses
lettres c'est comment vous dire c'est
presque les chefs-d'œuvre de la
littérature épistolière amoureuse et ça
ça m'a fait beaucoup de plaisir même si
je vous lis le livre tordu parce que
chaque fois je ramène à la crise
actuelle je donne voilà voilà les ils
sont quand il y a les erreurs et ça
mélange le passé et l'actualité et on va
parler justement actualités l'armée
russe qui reconnaît une situation tendue
est-ce que la Russie en général mais
est-ce que la Russie est en train de
perdre cette guerre pour vous
savez pour non je vais vous citer le
vice-ministre de la Défense ukrainien
qui a dit qu'il ne faut pas vendre la
peau de l'ours de l'ours avant de le
tuer
vous comprenez il y a il y a une chose
que vous devez savoir moi j'ai des
origines craignantes et une grande
sympathie je vis cette guerre comme
tragédie alors je fais je dois étouffer
mes sentiments personnels et deuxième
chose je vous préviens que dans cette
guerre il y a beaucoup de
désinformations c'est au fait c'est la
guerre de la part de qui de la formation
de l'Occident les deux il ne faut pas se
lever
pourquoi parce que vous savez je vais
vous dire pourquoi c'est dangereux que
la guerre la guerre froide pendant la
guerre froide il y avait la propagande
il y avait la politique
aujourd'hui il y a un mélange de genre
il y a la propagande et la propagande
devient parfois la politique réelle les
gens montent et croit leur mensonges et
ça concerne hélas les analyses les
analyses doivent être pointues je vous
conseille pour regarder les situations
militaires j'ai deux alliés maintenant
qui dit comme moi qu'on vit la crise
terrible l'apocaléon veut laver
l'Apocalypse comparé la comparé la crise
actuelle avec la crise de Cuba et moi je
disais dès le début chez vous et il y a
une très grande dame américaine que je
vous conseille n'est pas très jolie mais
hyper agréable il dirige tous les
services secrets américains Hero Keynes
elle dit la chose suivante encore une
fois comme
dame j'aime beaucoup les dents c'est
pour ça que je viens chez vous et je
tiens à vous dire vous savez elle dit il
y a tout d'abord il y a cette percée de
ukrainien là-bas personne c'est plus
c'est ton symbole c'est il faut pas
sous-estimer parfois les gens disent non
mais il faut c'est un symbole très
important parce que la ville a accueilli
les Russes plutôt plutôt bien la
question d'une part ça c'est il y a une
concentration
si il y a un revers ça peut vraiment
changer la donne pour aller dans votre
sens deuxième pour personne c'est pas
qu'un symbole pour vous ça peut être un
peu mais les symboles pendant la guerre
ça ne suffit pas il y a les données
objectives mais la vraie bataille et
c'est une vraie bataille il y a certains
médias de les mails l'autre jour il a
parlé de bataille oubliée qui est
beaucoup plus important c'est la
bataille de barmouth c'est vous savez
les Ukrainiens ils ont construit une
sorte de
l'imaginons je dirais et cet environ de
ce cette ligne mais sinon là c'est
vraiment la bataille les deux batailles
maintenant ça peut déterminer
l'issue de la guerre mais je suis prêt à
aller dans votre sens avec moi
on n'était pas habitué à ce vocabulaire
reconnaisser le de la part de la Russie
reconnaissent une situation tendue
depuis le 24 février
auquel on est habitué
c'est en vocabulaire il y a un
changement de la gestion de la de
vraiment des affaires militaires en
Russie il y a
c'est ton langage de son nouveau
commandant en chef qui est apparu vous
avez vu
le muscle les les lui il était il a une
particularité
[Musique]
soroquine il s'appelle
et je l'ai croisé quand j'étais porte
parole autrefois des puccistes pendant
l'affaire de push de Moscou il était du
côté de moi je fais un petit
pulciste et je sors delsigne
complètement déprimée j'ai dit ils sont
quand même les pauvreté
ultime et je vois les Pucci pauvre type
et donc où on m'a demandé de gérer une
affaire très tendue il y avait les gens
dont ils ont été tués et il apparaît ce
général que je vous conseille aussi
regarder comme cette Américaine de près
et lui il parle il parle de langage de
la vérité mais pour l'instant
la bataille sera très acharnée c'est la
bataille qui peut changer la donne sur
le plan politique changer la dont je
vais dans sur le plan politique mais ça
peut se déterminant pour le destin de
baiden qui est en perte de vitesse parce
que bondé baiden maintenant c'est en
perte de vitesse terrible et si les
républicains arrivent avec les
perspectives de Trump qui ne portent pas
la politique de Biden à New krem dans
son cœur tout le contraire il est très
critique il dit qu'il amène qui nous
amène la guerre mondiale etc il y a les
accusations terribles et si les uns pour
vous ce qui se passe c'est prochains
jours en Ukraine ça peut avoir des
conséquences sur les élections aux
États-Unis
et ça c'est ça ça reflète quoi ça s'il
était si sûr qu'il gagne sur le terrain
évidemment elle n'aurait jamais demander
la frappe nucléaire parce que c'est
vraiment l'arme de dernier recours alors
le restaurant sur cette dame
ukrainien il faut pas vendre la peau de
l'ours avant de le tuer sur cette avenue
nucléaire que Vladimir Poutine aussi
menace d'utiliser pour vous c'est du
bluff de la part de Vladimir
vous avez remarqué
j'étais j'ai eu deux alliés inattendus
d'une part Biden qui parle de comparer
ça avec la crise de Cuba et puis j'ai
travaillé autrefois pour gorbation fait
avant de mourir
il dit
dernier message on est la veille de
l'Apocalypse et je partage ça pourquoi
parce que si votre analyse est bonne le
jour créé gagne la guerre je demande je
crains qu'est-ce qu'ils veulent faire
ils veulent libérer la Crimée ils
veulent peindre Poutine et certains
ukrains reprennent les paroles de
l'ancien projet président polonais
Valencia qui dit qu'il faut scinder les
Russie en 5 et puissent la frappe
nucléaire mais bref tout ça un jour vous
signale que entre être pendu avec ma
modeste qu'on connaissance du Kremlin je
vous préviens je suis absolument certain
que j'ai étudié le caractère de Poutine
vous savez j'ai fait 4-5 livres je suis
poutine au logo je tiens à vous dire je
suis absolument certain qu'il va
utiliser ce qu'il larmes qui lui reste
et sur leur tactique il faut dire que
c'est une affaire presque technique ils
disent qu'il y a le supériorité
évidente de l'OTAN sur le plan des armes
con éternel mais les Russes ils ont une
supériorité en arme tactique 8 à 1 en
leur faveur et dans ce domaine
stratégique sur cinq points 5 points ils
sont supérieurs aux Américains de
quelques années à venir vous comprenez
ça c'est le scénario deuxième scénario
existe c'est le scénario de Poutine
paradoxalement il progresse mais dans ce
cas là je tiens vous prévenir ils vont
aller au dessin et cette fois-ci les
Américains me disent la domination russe
dans la mer Noire au dessin c'est
inacceptable on va trouver texto le
prétexte pour intervenir mais qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire c'est toujours la
guerre les Américains pourraient
intervenir
à mon sens les Russes d'ailleurs
sous-estime ça parce que les Russes ils
disent les Américains ne vont pas aller
jusqu'à l'intervention directe mais
l'intervention ça peut être
d'une manière différente on est entre
les gens sérieux mais ce que moi j'étais
aux États-Unis
pour j'ai vu vraiment les décideurs
là-bas et il me disent si les Russes
vont au dessin on va trouver un texto je
vous dis le prétexte et tout ça ça nous
ramène pourquoi je suis je ne dors pas
la nuit parfois et je ne dors pas la
nuit pas pour même pas pour les 14
degrés pendant l'hiver pas pour les les
vous savez les
la crise même pas pour l'Afrique qui est
qu'on va connaître la famille que j'aime
beaucoup l'Afrique mais je ne dors pas
pour vos enfants et pour nous mes
petits-enfants je pense qu'il faut
essayer de prévenir cette
issue qui est pour moi sera issu fatal
pour la civilisation
sur Poutine puisque vous dites vous le
connaissez bien évidemment il a annexé 4
régions ce qui n'est pas reconnu par la
communauté internationale est-ce que
pour lui c'était un moyen selon vous de
donner des gages à son opinion
c'est un bivalent
vous avez vous poser une vraie question
parce que Poutine un phénomène Poutine
est lié avec l'évolution de l'opinion
publique et l'opinion publique ça
conduit il continue à le soutenir
paradoxalement à 75% c'est pas bidon ça
c'est vraiment le soutien en même temps
il y a en même temps il y a quand même
la baisse de la popularité dans les
grandes villes les jeunes ne veulent pas
quand même aller
le combat mais en gros en gros il a plus
ou moins avec le bordel habituel russe
il a plus ou moins réussi
la mobilisation qui peut changer la
donne parce que la mobilisateur les gens
mobilisés ils vont arriver dans trois
semaines à peu près donc ça c'est réussi
parler de ces russes qui quittaient la
Russie pour échapper à la mobilisation
vous vous dites la mobilisation
j'ai beaucoup de sympathie pour ces
gens-là parce que c'est souvent c'est
les gens qui ont avec qui j'étais dans
le milieu démocratique mais je pense que
Poutine les pousse aussi par partir en
quelque sorte il veut éliminer ce qu'il
appelle la cinquième colonne dans les
dans les choses même si on ne peut pas
sous-estimer une sorte de grogne dans
les grandes villes parmi les jeunes soit
soyons très clair il y a un point sur
lequel on peut jouer entre la Russie et
des campagnes et la Russie des grandes
villes dans le soutien Vladimir
principale c'est ça Petersbourg
Moscou et éventuellement 3e ville
à oral même il y a une chose qui peut
sur lequel on peut s'appuyer vous avez
compris que je suis très inquiet et je
pense que les cieux de cette guerre
doit être trouvé pour éviter le pire
et la majorité de l'opinion publique
russe il faut jouer sur ça
je publie en faveur de négociations
malheureusement les négociations c'est
pas de mal à laver malheureusement il
n'y a même pas les appels vous savez ce
qui appelle maintenant en agression à ce
c'est le feu
la Chine l'Inde
l'Arabie Saoudite la Turquie qui négocie
en sourdine Israël il y a il y a
on va y revenir mais vous qui connaissez
bien Poutine est-ce qu'il a tempérament
à négocier
c'est le premier Poutine jusqu'au
boutiste celui qui était formé par la
mafia de San Peter par la pègre de
Saint-Pétersbourg celui qui va qui nous
recule jamais il y a les règles de la
peine qui est dans son
âme son action et puis qui signe gère il
considère que la chance qu'il était au
KGB pourquoi parce que le KGB c'est
pragmatique il était officier du KGB il
doit affronter
ça j'ai parlé de votre vous poser les
vraies questions je suis très sensible
ça j'ai posé la même question à
quelqu'un qui a géré la crise de Cuba
qui était le bras droit de McNamara et
il méprise les gens d'aujourd'hui pour
vous dire la vérité et la distille si on
a géré la crise de Cuba parce que leur
principal préoccupation c'est de trouver
Lucius sauver il a utilisé le mot en
prononçable aujourd'hui SAU surface des
uns et des autres même aller la solution
c'est simple dans deux solutions c'est
la guerre mondiale troisième solution
c'est la guerre pour l'éternité le
dindon de la farce de l'Europe mais dans
ce cas-là on va se battre jusqu'où
jusqu'où jusqu'au dernier jusqu'au
dernier russe je pense que ça peut
changer les données il faut regarder
pour l'avenir je sais pas par hasard que
je vous ai cité ce général le nouveau
chef
je tiens à vous dire il y a aussi en
Ukraine en général très vigoureux qui
gère ses opérations
vous allez venir s'appelle et tous ces
généraux ils sont conscients des pertes
épouvantables et épouvantable là-bas
dans la juste l'offensive de de
personnes vous savez combien de 20000
personnes donc ça pousserait négociation
mais vous je que vous connaissez bien
Belém mais en fait une vous connaissez
aussi bien l'entourage de Vladimir
Poutine est-ce que dans son entourage il
y a des pros négociations des prospects
et est-ce qu'ils ont des chances d'être
entendu par Vladimir Poutine il y a des
deux tendances allez je vais vous donner
les deux tendances pour la première il y
a tendance shaggo ce ministre de la
Défense chaman le nom de code chaman
comme il vient deltaï il y a
la joie le premier adjoint l'ancien
Premier ministre qui reviennent quoi qui
sont des gens plutôt jusqu'au-boutiste
et d'une manière générale et puis il y a
il y a toujours les nuances entre les
services secrets et l'armée et cette
mise en scène qu'on a connu au
développement le premier jour vous
souvenez quand il a gueulé contre
c'était la mise en scène évidemment mais
en revanche il y a ce monsieur les
services secrets il y a aussi le chef de
l'administration présidentielle ils sont
ils sont disons plus nuancés sur ce plan
là mais je ne vais pas aller jusqu'à
dire qu'il y a les faucons et les
colombes mais les discussions sont
incontestablement là d'où vient la
nomination de ce de ce personnage assez
extraordinaire à la tête de l'armée et
on va voir ce qui donne d'une manière
générale je tiens à dire pour les gens
qui nous écoutent nous regardent je
tiens à vous dire une chose on vit avec
personne avec barmouth les moins les
décisifs pour l'avenir de l'Europe pour
vos assurances vie pour nos enfants
personne c'est ton point vous avez
raison deuxième point bonne base
troisième point et deux généraux je vous
ai cité de de généraux qui gère l'armée
il y a deux généraux à regarder le
général automne parce que le temps est
dégueulasse là-bas pourquoi à personne
maintenant ils ont fait les orphelins
les contre-attaques et comme il pleut
aujourd'hui
commence à jouer en faveur des des ça ne
joue pas en faire des ukrainien parce
que c'est plus difficile quand il y a
aller et puis il y a un autre général
plus aléatoire je vais vous dire encore
une fois parce que le général hiver
traditionnellement sans faveur des
Russes mais les Ukrainiens sont les
mêmes comprenez que vous voyez c'est
assez d'une part même il y a le fait que
les armes russes assez rustiques ils
sont plus adaptés au froid objectivement
sur le fond des négociations parce que
si négociations il y a un jour il va
bien falloir un compromis est-ce que
Vladimir Poutine peut lâcher une partie
des quatre régions qui est la
nouvellement annexée et est-ce que le
point crucial c'est la Crimée
la Crimée beaucoup de gens pensent que
c'est la Crimée masque on a parlé vous
savez le gars américains mais si vous
récapitule les gens qui sont pour
négociation vous serez étonné c'est
Sarkozy c'est en partie Macron de qui a
proposé quand même un plan très très
sophistiqué que j'ai toujours soutenu
vous souvenez son discours quand il a
fait à Strasbourg qui est un discours
assez important c'est un feuille d'euros
de négociation il y a aussi ce processus
de paix manuel Macron aujourd'hui je
regrettais beaucoup mais je souligne
l'importance de ce plan de paix qui est
qui est un c'est pas en plan mais c'est
un feuille de route de l'ouverture la
prononcer les mots des escalades et les
prononcer le mot pas d'exclusion pas
d'humiliation c'est les mots qui compte
je crois francophilie que je suis à
l'importance de la diplomatie française
dans la tradition à la fois goliant mais
aussi fait partie de Mitterrand avec sa
maison commune et la confédération
européenne tout ça ça compte mais en
France il y a beaucoup de gens qui
partagent mon avis et je pense que entre
ces trois essieux la guerre à l'infini
qui est plein de risques
ou l'Europe sera dans donc de la foire
sous on va virer vivre les choses très
difficiles sur le la crise financière
aussi en faveur de de négociation joue
en facteur très important je vous ai
parlé des problèmes de la politique
antérieure américain même les Américains
sont préoccupés par l'homme cette crise
terrible qu'on vit en Europe mais c'est
cette fois la crise arrive là-bas il y a
la récession qui arrive là-bas et ça
peut changer les donne comme l'arrivée
de républicains et je vous dis au Sénat
et
un dernier mot Vladimir il nous reste
une minute qui peut aujourd'hui mettre
un terme à cette guerre qui peut
convaincre Vladimir Poutine de négocier
et est-ce qu'il y a quelque chose qui
pourrait faire que ce conflit des raps
je suis plus que jamais inquiet je vous
expliquais comme on analyse ce mot
pousse à croire qu'on est vraiment on va
vers la guerre pour vous on va toujours
pour vous on est toujours à la veille du
3e guerre mondiale les plus probables
les plus probables
je pense qu'il y a la majorité des pays
la majorité de la population du monde la
Chine l'Inde je vous ai dit c'est quand
même une grande majorité
97% de de de
pays exige le cessez le feu la majorité
des Russes sont en faveur en faveur le
CC le feu et j'espère que Dieu sera avec
nous en tout cas je constate qu'en
France il y a des gens de tout premier
plan vous avez le choix entre la
Védrines tout tout le monde il exige
quand même l'exécution de ce plan qui
est très sophistiqué le plan de Macron
de Strasbourg je reste on va revenir je
souhaite que la France joue un rôle
primordial dans son dans ce processus
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous
vous aurez évidemment l'occasion de
venir nous en parler merci je remontre
votre livre roman d'une révolution c'est
aux éditions ballon merci merci beaucoup
d'avoir été notre invité ce matin on va
[Musique]